when I first became a Fed
to the fellow in law
and I'm ignore called Tony honoré said
to me do animals have law and I wasn't
really able to give us a straight answer
to that I was impressed with Rebecca's
historical demonstration of the way
things improve and obviously it Steve
pink has written about this he got a
community and I've long felt that the
way I put the same point is that we who
live in the early 21st century are
labeled as 21st century moralists of
people with 21st century values the
difference between the extremes of today
they say thee and another george w bush
or the donald rumsfeld after of today
and the more progressive elements today
is smaller than the difference between
the anybody today and anybody not just a
hundred years ago maybe even 50 years
ago that it's dramatic the way our moral
values the one that everybody accepts
not the ones that we reason about as
moral philosophers but the ones that
simply are part of the culture part of
dinner party conversation just the
ordinary assumptions in the 19th century
th Huxley I suppose was in the vanguard
of progressive liberal thought but it
would never once have occurred to th
Huxley that black people were remotely
comparable to white people in ability
with just just just a given and one one
mean to Huxley used Rather's of
patronizing language about about black
people so we're all changing from
century to century from decade to decade
and this seems to be at as Rebecca said
a kind of not exactly irreversible
process but there's very little evidence
that it's ever that he's ever reversed
now if we extrapolate into the future i
Peter Singh is not here but I'm very
struck by the fact that the whole
conversation is about Matt
my thing Happiness greatest happiness
the greatest number there's an implicit
human stuck in there and when you think
as an evolutionist there doesn't seem to
be any reason to do that I mean it's
it's almost just that it's a a
historical accident a very convenient
accident that all the intermediates
between ourselves and other species
happen to be extinct that's why we're
able to talk about morality as though it
was a purely human problem as though the
the only alternative to what we just
argue about whether we go with with
Steven Weinberg and say we we look after
our our own family or we worry about
that people starving in India or
something what about the other species
and I just like to add one thought since
I've been asked about animal behavior
when you when when you take when you
take Bentham's famous remark about the
question is not can they think can they
reason but can they suffer if you
actually ask what suffering is for what
the Darwinian function of suffering is
it's clearly to teach a lesson to the
animal don't do that again
if you've just done something that gives
you pain don't repeat it and and that's
all has obvious Darwinian Darwinian
value now if you ask yourself those
species that can think and reason how
much pain would they need in order to
deter them from doing something silly
again the answer is surely well at least
we should consider the answer to be they
need less pain if they can think and
reason then it should take a less
painful sting stimulus to put them off
doing the silly thing again whereas an
animal that cannot think and reason or
is very poor at thinking and reasoning
is going to need more pain and so far
from assuming that a species which can
think and reason probably has a greater
capacity to suffer which we I think I'm
too
they all do we might actually at least
consider the opposite proposition that a
species that can think and reason has
less capacity to suffer I'm not
necessarily arguing for that but at
least it's something that we should
consider without just just even ignoring
it
you